laura bundeck from sky
i'm secretary of state earlier today the
prime minister warned about complacency
at this dangerous moment in the pandemic
and yet
nearly three weeks ago he was allowing
people to socialize indoors
over christmas was that complacent and
are we paying the price for that now
well we're seeing that the new variant
of the virus is incredibly transmissible
it's contagious highly contagious
and the fact that it spreads so so
easily from one person to the other
means that we have this incredibly
difficult
few weeks ahead of us whilst we get the
vaccination plan
rolled out as we were just discussing
and it's imperative that everybody
not just follows the rules and not just
sees the rules as a limit that should be
stretched
but rather behaves as if they have the
virus
and limits the amount of social contact
that everybody has and i know that's
difficult
i honestly i really do but
it's so important for everybody and so
don't flex the rules i've said before
that a flex
to the rules can be fatal what i mean by
that is if people push the boundaries of
these rules or
don't take them seriously then that can
lead to
more infections and that can lead to
more deaths
and the vast majority of people are
following the rules
but it's very very important that
everybody does
steve yes and i think one thing that
it's really easy sometimes to forget
is that as the nhs gets under more
pressure
from increasing numbers of patients with
covid it's not just those coved patients
where services come under pressure it's
patients who don't have covid as well
become affected
because the ability of the nhs to
provide its full range of services
becomes more and more difficult so when
the public
when all of us comply with these
measures and really pay attention to the
detail of complying with them
then we're not just helping our nhs
staff treat covet patients
but we're helping our nhs staff ensure
that they can treat patients with
strokes
who have heart attacks who are in
traffic accidents
so it's really critical at this really
serious moment
that we all pull together to ensure
not only reduce deaths from covid but
that we ensure that the nhs
is to do what it's always done for all
of us which is to treat us and keep us
safe
at our time of need and i just want to
come back to the core of the question
that you asked
you know this new variant makes
this so much harder but it doesn't just
make it so much harder for
for us at the podium it makes it harder
for everyone because it means that
everyone has to
has to restrict the things that they
love more
than would have been previously
necessary under the
under the old variant and that is tough
on us all but thankfully we've got this
way out
with the with the vaccine so let's not
blow it now